bienvenue pour le 7-8 sport merci de
nous rejoindre toujours sur tv fil 78 le
tour de l'actualité sportive du week end
26 minutes avec anthony rech bonsoir
wilfried bonsoir à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 sport nous
reviendrons sur la quinzaine de roland
garros mais vu par un jeune ramasseur de
balle que nous avons suivis pendant le
tournoi le plaisir roy thomas mouly je
recevrai également jean charles loeb le
cycliste évinois qui a relié à vélo la
ville en espagne 2 par là à montcuq dans
le lot et puis évidemment en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end je sens que ça vous fait déjà
sourire wilfried non c'est votre
prononciation comment vous prononcer
cette fameuse ville donc je suis comme
ça qui est les villageois et les
habitants
tiennent à la prononciation mais vous
savez comment je suis taquin sur la
géographie sur les villes françaises
comme la semaine dernière ont commencé
par roland garros oui au roland garros
un thomas évidemment tu as passé trois
semaines dans un des plus beaux tournois
du monde du côté de la porte d'auteuil
en tant que ramasseur de balle tu avais
été sélectionné alors ton meilleur
souvenir sur ces trois semaines qu'est
ce qu'elle est il
j'en ai plusieurs il ya eu la première
journée la première ouverture de haut
rang gorges étaient sur le central et
j'avais d'ailleurs agacé l'animal de
rodger federer mais ce jour-là public
était le public était plein et c'était
assez impressionnant la première fois et
les deux trois autres souvenirs
peut-être d'abord je sais que tu es venu
avec quelque chose de particulier
n'était pas venu les mains vides ce soir
la raquette de besoin d'air tu peux nous
l'a montré oui
c'est en fait l est pas oui
effectivement bon alors pas beaucoup
joué avec un voile ah bon alors explique
aux équipes nous un petit peu alors
pourquoi les haies les cas c'est comme
ça alors c'était au match 2 contre kei
nishikori je crois et je crois qu'ils
étaient menés mais il avait un peu pété
les boulons il avait cassé d'un co je
crois que ce n'est pas très content de
son match ou affection commentent a
réussi à aller récupérer sa traque est
bas en fait j'ai froid j'ai été sur
images les récupérer j'avais mon coach
qui m'a dit de là mais derrière et à la
fin du match m'a récupéré il n'a pas
pris parfois ils apprennent et on la
tire au sort et c'est tombé sur moi
voilà ce huitième de finale de benoît
paire qu'il avait perdu le français
qu'elle était le plus dur sur le court
là pendant que tu étais en poste on va
dire le plus dur à faire sur pendant les
matchs c'était de ne pas regarder la
balle circulait parce qu'on sait que
vous n'avez pas le droit de trop
regarder les points par exemple dans ce
changement de ballon hachey qu'elle est
mal
tu veux regarder sur le fond a pas une
balle parce que des fois c'est
aujourd'hui on a tassé tout le temps
concentré toujours les moyens vois tu
commences à ce moment là parce qu'on
voit en train de ramasser les balles tu
es concentré tu ne penses qu'à la balle
tu peux poser la raclée temps de pause
nationale pense que que au match que la
rattraper la balle tu regardes pas le
match d'ailleurs tu regardes pas les
échanges non parce que trop score en
fait on les voit frapper la balle mais
on pense surtout à la balle allait au
prochain changement de pratiques
centrées voix
très concentré le jour on vous en avez
souvient d'ailleurs le but premier
mercredi en fait de la première semaine
est alors justement l'année prochaine tu
aura peut-être le droit d'y retourner ça
te donne envie de ramasser à nouveau
parce quand même trois semaines donc ça
c'est long je sais pas si je le referais
surtout que bon ça fait quand même trois
semaines genre de l'éco fiel brevets
l'année prochaine mais je crois que
c'est en novembre prochain au prochain
octobre
j'aimerais bien tenter bercy c'est
possible le master ski qui a lieu à la
fin de l'automne du côté de bercy alors
côtoyer tous ces joueurs rodger federer
je sais que tu as ramasser les balles de
rafael nadal dans la deuxième semaine
aussi ça fait rêver j'imagine non c'est
bon rodgers avait été deux fois j'avais
ramassé deuxième fois en connaissent un
peu plus éthiques il avait il menait
toujours les mêmes choses en début de
match
rafa nadal c'est vrai que ça c'est
impressionnant
l'isra il a beaucoup de tic aussi bien
mais franchement avec les avec les
joueurs comme ça et vous demandent des
choses particulier machinalement
toujours plus de servette bon temps
d'abord en mettre une près de 90 2 3
rafa nadal comprend jusqu'à 5,6
puisqu'il en est déjà une sur chaque
chaise d'arbitré derrière lui un sur les
jus de lime par exemple
mais les deux ramasseurs de fond en est
en chacun une qui prend les deux chaque
fois après il sonné pour le sac pour la
raquette alors c'est peut-être secret
professionnel mais tu peux peut-être
nous dire ça se passe comment les
joueurs ils sont plutôt sympas pas sympa
et c'est l'horreur il ya les français
alors le
moins sympa je pense que s'il y en a
voilà d'accord
avec
moi j'avais donné des serviettes et il
m'avait mal parlé je crois ah ouais
ouais je suis de ma vie alors s'il veut
répondre
c'est l'occasion ou jamais est alors le
plus le plus sympa des français on parle
souvent des blue tsonga est ce que c'est
lui sont bien je l'avais ramasser mais
j'étais pas sa chaise donc je vais pas
donner les bouteilles les serviettes
mais je pense qu'il y assez sympa
mon fils que j'ai pas ramassé avait
l'air très sympa avec les ramasseurs
choix qui avait gagné où ils avaient
mangé avec les ramasseurs il avait un
peu parlé avec lui plutôt sympa et alors
dans les grands joueurs les stars du
circuit ça vous intéresse antonio pas
les connaître et de savoir voilà les
coulisses de roland garros est
intéressant lequel voilà avec qui tu as
pu échanger un petit peu même si vous
n'avez pas trop loin de la charge et je
crois que j'échange avec aucun joueur 1
j'ai vu cette année c'est marca qu'il
avait croisé dans un couloir qu'il avait
bon jour mais bon on a pas trop notre
discuter avec les joueurs maintenant que
tu retour mais n'ont pas encore à
l'école si aujourd'hui et alors ça s'est
passé comment le retour à l'école j'ai
un peu du mal au début c'est si dur
enfin le rythme est là bas trois
semaines soit sa radio 1 c'est compliqué
non c'est tout le monde te poses des
questions
parfois un peu quelques-unes comment ça
s'est passé les professeurs je suis sûr
qu'ils ont posé des questions
et tu as réussi ajustements à garder le
rythme
de l'école le soir après après les
matchs tu arrivé à rattraper les tous
les cours genêt j'avais pas le temps
fait en revenait vers 22h on est assez
crever la journée on partait vers 21h
21h21 ira mieux ça dépend des démarches
vu que j'avais mon correspondant que
devait attendre qu'ils mangent pour
qu'on puisse se supporter longtemps
encore rendre à cet art est fatigué donc
on dort mediact précise un élève de 4e
au collège de feu strohl fécherolle en
sport études et lisez aussi appelé ses
licenciés appelé coccinelle un programme
spécial est alors voir tous et tous ses
joueurs les côtoyer au plus près ça te
donne envie à toi justement joueurs de
dire à jean vidal est encore plus
travaillé à l'entraînement et de de
faire monter ce petit classement c'est
vrai ça booste un peu on dit ça va pas
leur c'est difficile de jeu lundi au
rendez-vous à jouer ça alors c'est bon
prix en revient à l'entraînement c'est
un peu plus difficile mais très que ça
donne envie de continuer quand même
qu'après on peut tout se permettre même
de cassé sa raquette quand j'avais pas
content
merci beaucoup thomas pour ces de ce
beau retour d'expérience et puis on
espère que tu seras donc parmi les
ramasseurs l'année prochaine à lisbonne
fin d'année scolaire puisque c'est pas
encore terminée je crois
le rabat joie de venir au sérieux
renault ça y est c'est sérieux et puis
c'est pas forcément très sympathique
pour le club de montigny volé ma
exactement wilfried montigny recevait ce
week end les demi finales et finales de
la coupe des yvelines de volley après
s'être sauvé lors des phases de barrage
le club mini monte avait l'occasion de
finir en beauté et de récupérer un
trophée sur cette saison restait encore
à s'imposer face à sartrouville récite
ce match avec julien au chasseresse
pour cette demi finale de coupe des
yvelines montigny a dû faire avec les
moyens du bord à cause de l'absence de
certains titulaires composé de six types
s'est avéré être un vrai puzzle
d'ailleurs dès les premiers points
l'entente des saint quentinois en blanc
est loin d'être parfaite les blocs sont
friables et des espaces restent
désespérément vides en défense la ligne
d'attaqué n'est pas beaucoup plus
efficace trop de ce match ratée de
services en précis donné des points
gratuits à sartrouville
dans le premier set ils sont rapidement
menés 8 2 puis vingt dix et offre la
première manche sur une nouvelle photo
service
bis repetita dans le second acte les
joueurs d'abdellatif micheli ne se
révolte pas et encaissent un
indiscutable 25 14 ils n'ont rien pu
faire face à l'expérience sartrouville
oise un adversaire qui comptait dans ses
rangs deux joueurs ayant évolué en
national et qui vient d'obtenir sa
montée en régionale une après avoir
arraché leur maintien lors de la phase
de barrage les joueurs et nous montrent
un semblait sans ressources comme
épuisés par leur fin de saison je
m'attendais à une contre performance
mais vraiment prince prend la porte donc
pourtant dans le jeu on a essayé de
relever la tête de jouer
au niveau de l'attitude
je suis pas du tout montré vraiment mon
image de
d'une équipe qui se laissent faire qui
suivit alors pas du tout comme ça on m'a
dit se battre pour un maintien qui était
vraiment pas facile on a on a tout donné
on
on s'est battu
montrer une image complètement
différente sur sur cinq six matches on
s'est battu pendant cinq six matches
mais là on avance était vraiment
concrètement l'opposé de ce qu'on est
capable ou faire en finale conflent
s'impose 2 sets à 1 face à sartrouville
et remporte cette coupe des yvelines
version 2013